nous allons maintenant évoqué un
problème grave
l'exclusion et je vais recevoir
quelqu'un qui en souffrent le héros
d'une série culte
tout le monde le connaît mais jamais
personne ne l'invitent à la télévision
voici l'homme invisible
merci bonsoir soir tient visiblement
soir ça me gêne un peu de pâte voir
est-ce que quasi claudio est ce qu'on
pourrait lui m s'excuse moi on va te
donner je pars un chapeau quelque chose
merci voilà ce à quoi vous avez ça non
mais c'est pour l'homme invisible
oui la main visible pourquoi quoi
comment c'était arrivé ce truc là tu es
né comme ça ou c'est un c'est un
accident bab en fait je dois te dire
c'est quand même plutôt un drame
à cette époque là j'étais étudiant en
chimie un jour de 1897 bon
il ya une expérience un peu poussé je
dois dire de hg wells tue c'est
l'inventeur de la machine à remonter le
temps en soins et bataves l'accident
bête l'invisibilité totale et définitive
ça fait un siècle que ça dure cette
étude qui en souffrent tutu vit ça
comment as tu sais dès qu'on est
différent le regard des autres vous le
fait sentir
tu te sens victime d'un certain racisme
de finale non le pire dans mon cas c'est
pas le racisme c'est la différence des
gens moi je moi je pourrais crevé à côté
d'eux sans qu'ils s'en aperçoivent
enfin la visibilité ça quand même des
bons côtés je vais avec les gonzesses
bon d'accord
bon c'est sûr tu utilises incognito dans
l'ici dit crawford bon quoi une fois
devant dijon 2 3 vous hein
enfin tu as fait le tour des bons côtés
un lot reste c'est vraiment
cauchemardesque comment ça que ce n'est
d'abord d'abord beaufort oui mais moi
j'ai pas de vie de famille il est si
c'est même pas la peine d'avoir des
enfants si c'est pour qu'il me voit
jamais un ensuite impossible de trouver
un job stable
un bon tu connais les gens ils sont
méfiants ils veulent savoir à qui ils
ont affaire chaque fois soit en fait tu
me dire à moi mes enfants ne voient pas
souvent non plus bien mon job il n'est
pas vraiment stable non plus enfin bon
tout est celle d'anton cas parce que
l'actuel pompeux mais finalement ben non
je sais pas enfin tu gare à six il y en
ad'autres je les vois pas enfin c'est
quand même devenu une star par rapport
aux autres et enfin bon il paraît qu'on
voit partout
moi personnellement j'ai du mal à y
croire parce qu'on peut produire que je
vois partout ça fait d'événements mois
juillet tout petits avaient déjà l'homme
accord et la télé d'accord thierry mais
tu peux pas dire que je crève l'écran
un sa faille et un film où t'es pas mal
là que j'ai vu dernièrement frigide tu
peux nous nous montrer la fosse wharf
rigide et transparent
mais c'est vous le maître parce que vous
ne vous nous avez scotché sur ce coup là
merci
[Musique]
à
bravo
coûte vraiment d'accord d'accord
d'accord merci merci c'est super bien
roulé
ça doit être un bonheur oui mais pas
d'accord mais c'est encore ma partenaire
qui m'a piqué la vedette enfin bon n'ont
pas tourné nue sata projet nettoie eu
beau jeu puis cgg vraiment rien à cacher
ouais
est ce qu'à un truc que tu ferais pas à
l'écran à ce qu'un rôle que tu refuses
d'incarner oui personnellement
maintenant je refuse mais vraiment
catégoriquement les bandits bande est le
truc dans moi chaque fois qu'ils
acceptent de ne montrer il mettait un
stupide déguisement de momies despentes
est moi je non vraiment je supporte plus
ces bandelettes gentil on ira une fois
la calme toi tu as non mais c'est ça
dépend des tu comprends et je comprends
mais tu as un projet là une émission de
télé oui oui je bientôt sur la une à ce
savant oui je fais un perdu de vue ah
mais c'est bien d'un coup tu reviens
quand tu veux parce que nous on est
d'accord c'était sympa pour se voir est
ce que tu veux que je te des matériels
et bah écoute j'attends que ça enfin si
tu
ça marche pas quasi que l'on regarde al
akwaa mais voilà il revient en vrai
maintenant d'une danse et ramsès ii qui
est invisible que j'arrive pas de
matérialiser mais s'avèrent des fois
c'est être une ville de la lésion mon
vieux j'ai regardé c'est le truc bulle
parce qu'il ya eu dans le juriste et il
était boucher chez paquet jean-pierre là
là c'est bon là pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus